good morning millennial good morning
Millennials welcome back to the morning
dose actually bad morning millenials
today's a horrible awful treacherous day
I just really am NOT it's very Monday
yet a rough weekend I feel like Monday's
like Mondays haven't been so Monday ever
since like the toast is really popping
off and I really do love I love my work
but today is a struggle they say if you
love what you do you'll never work it
anyway but I love what I do but I work
every day explain but I've really been
like loving like enjoying thoroughly
what we do but today was one of those
days where it's just like I don't know
how much I have to give him and give you
a ahh but I don't know what that looks
like I mean I had a flood in my house
like I cannot be here right now
Noah's Ark season the CEO ender two by
two honestly thank god Margo was there
because she helped Theo back because you
know he wants like look up all the
toilet water of course he did he wanted
to help Mom and clean up no he didn't he
wanted to make it worse for me I wish
you could have heard my voice like when
the toilet I was doing my hair in the
bathroom and I felt a little water on my
sock and I was like what and I looked
down and the toilets [ __ ] overflowing
nothing worse than a wet sock and I am
screaming like I don't know how to get
it to stop like I don't know what what
even goes on you know and I took that
thing off the back of the toilet he's
just really much situated or out of
nowhere the hole it's very I'm having a
lot of problems plumbing wise in this
apartment and the toilet had been acting
up so we like stopped using it and then
I guess it just decided to like throw up
and it was so crazy it flooded or my
closet the bathroom then once we finally
got it all cleaned up we had to have a
vacuum the next day like the hardwood
starts literally bubbling I have to show
you pictures like my floor is cracked I
could see like this cement oh my god I
don't have to get that replaced like
it's a whole [ __ ] nightmare I'm sorry
well and my owner is calling me hold on
I have to pick it up okay um I guess I
could talk hello you know when I talk
about my hair because yeah actually I
guess it doesn't work if Claudia is
talking to so I'll wait hmm oh you have
her mic down okay I'll talk about my
hair so the other night what a night I
went to a 70s party okay for my friend
Rebecca Gibson's birthday and I just
like had this idea to do like Cher
inspired hair so I bought these
extensions from Ricky's because
you guys know like I lost my premium ass
extensions and they really didn't think
they were gonna look good but I put them
in and everyone was so obsessed with
them so now I'm definitely growing my
hair back out and I'm gonna get custom
extensions again that fit my hair color
so that I can like wear them on the show
and stuff because they looked a little
janky on Saturday night if you were with
me in person in pictures they looks good
but in person they were like a little
janky not gonna lie but anyways it was
really inspiring and I'm so glad you
guys all liked it cuz every time I used
to put my extensions in before people
would miss my short hair but not anymore
we found it in the bathtub and it's from
the shelf that holds the shampoo they
found it in the bathtub but and it's
from the shelf that holds a shampoo oh
and of course my t-shirt today is how to
Maison Couture how cute is this shirt he
did a really good job with his March
like I would wear this to the club for
sure
everything okay it's just it's a shock
you city it's like I moved in today I I
love and I hate a case of Shakey's
it's J'Accuse because I moved into this
apartment that is just it's beautiful
but it's a mirage and it's riddled with
issues and like I've lived there for
literally two weeks there's no way even
if I was so hard on the apartment that
any of these could be my problem and I'm
being very diligent every time I see
something I'm emailing the realtor and
the owner and it's like every time I
tell them it's like there's an
assumption of J'Accuse that like we did
it like I literally moved into the
apartment and in the master bathroom
were like these tiles that had obviously
fallen from the wall and I wrote an
email and sent a picture and now they're
all acting like they don't know what I'm
talking about
I'm a paying for any of this [ __ ] I
can't it's literally like a nightmare
I'm so sorry well at least you it's like
a really nice apartment and it was like
a really beautiful nightmare yeah there
are worse nightmares to be living in and
like you could live in a [ __ ] that
has everything working
what would you that's what I was
thinking this morning like okay so what
I rather be living in a in a bad
apartment but like everything works
great or in a beautiful apartment where
like I literally have to take 130 degree
showers because there's no cold water
you know yeah and as long as you're not
paying for everything it's okay no I
don't know that for sure but I'm just
letting you know I'm not pulling out my
wallet that's what I'm letting you know
great don't and I'm just being a good
historian I'm taking pictures and
everything emailing every time I
something like I'm being annoying to
everyone but like I don't ever want
there to be any assumption that I'm
paying for any of this right okay so I'm
sorry you're dealing with that I me too
I'm sorry like Theo ceiling with it
mostly because he doesn't deserve this
stress you know what else I'm sorry for
it's like I literally I'm out of my
house two hours a day and that's when
they decide to like have all the work
done right it's a [ __ ] I work from home
all day can you wait two hours sorry
sure where you boots from aqua Zara high
fashion see I've seen one Cerritos um
and Snitch has them in blue and she got
them like for her birthday and then I
was I really wanted them and she what I
did know what I did was I got the what
like the public desire versions for a
while and cuz I was like I don't need
like the most expensive ones and you
know what they look really cute in
pictures because I pull them up take a
picture and then they fall right back he
thought and it was really bad they would
literally come down to like here they
it's like kneesocks so I splurge but
they were on sale because I got them
late so I feel good about it okay friend
this my first time wearing them with my
Mason t-shirt oh my god I didn't even
realize you're right he's not the one
you got for free no this is I got from
his merch store how much was it 40
something very reason did it come in
like a good time period it really did I
thought it was gonna take away I thought
they would be ready to order but he
really has his [ __ ] together like Mason
Ramsay Productions is just turning out
premium content I'm generating know it I
mean I'm really happy for him and this
design is so cool like it's very cute
it's very in tune it's so rock and roll
like I was saying I would wear this
outfit to the club's it looks like I am
going to the clubs but since I don't
actually go to clubs back to where my
cute outfit I'm you know you go to like
countries except Saturday night we hit
the club we sort of we hit the town hard
oh yeah we did we did actually yeah I
forgot everybody can go to a club we
went to like a dingy bar and then we did
karaoke which was really fun
but we went hard yeah I really like
yesterday was hard for me yesterday was
a day that [ __ ] King just like fall off
my calendar because I woke up at 3
o'clock and I went to sleep at what I
midnight so like I was only alive for
yeah I just dealing with my friends so
like it was a lot more than that and I
actually started making preliminary
plans for our CMA Awards because we did
it last year and it was just critically
acclaimed so we have to do it again but
there's a lot of that gets involved in
getting approved to be on the red carpet
but we will get approve I'm so excited
but I better get like the nicest job I'm
gonna wait and then I went back
and I know by the way I was buying that
suit from the Nordstrom something
everything and it's sold out but that's
what I was gonna wear Oh cute oh my god
me shoe air power suits cuz that's
trying to do it looks like a bunch of
kids no and by the way I was watching
the footage and like I hated my [ __ ]
outfit but we were so funny but now I
look back on that footage and like
wanted to I because I had like a double
chin and an ugly outfit no I was
watching the footage and like my arm is
so big and pale but it's like the rest
of me is is good size so it's just an
unfortunate arm situation the whole time
and what it was just too good to even
focus on the arm but I was like lolling
at our interview of Brett Eldredge
because we were being so funny and they
put on my Instagram story and he
responded and followed me back wow
that's big because like that are you the
one on my inventory and what asthma did
they run it a good one like a popular
one a good one and he has Hebrew tattoos
so I think he's Jewish she's named Zach
yeah but he has to I rebel taste in
women Zach one room no a different like
almost to Mecca I can't get him to
message me back but I'm working on it
stars just I guess also when in the CMA
highlight reel when being insane we were
like we need to calm down that was after
we saw the stars of Nashville and we
were like hold right change we really
like we killed it and we drink whiskey
and we're doing it again
we're and better than ever now that I
feel like we establish ourselves I'm
hoping they make up it's like a little
bit more space like them knowing what we
did we were out for the CMAs and we
really need to get our tech production
in order that's something right that's
what I'm working with
yeah gun well so media credentials and
then also travel but the CMAs respect
the hell out of the morning toast well
we'll see but the date but the CMA oh
yeah
they perfected the hell out my see if
they let us come back you've to get
approved if you wanna be on the red
carpet like if they let us come back
that would mean that they liked what we
did last year right so I'm just hoping
them giving us aren't one box for CMA
fest meant that they liked what we did
on the red carpet I forgot that they
gave us our box speaking of boxes I went
to that cheering concert right me and
Margo went with Movado and so we sat in
a box it's like when you're sitting in a
bottle as a watch or watch yeah are you
um are you Jordan Rogers does he move on
oh I think he moves well yeah I'm about
it was much more upscale please but me
Margo both come about a watches and I
felt like a real lady because I never
wear watch
um but anytime we go to a concert in a
box like it's just premium and they gave
me a parking pass which made it so easy
at MetLife Stadium so I was happy
because like there was chicken-finger
was like it was chill in wine but I just
want to talk about the concert itself
for a minute not good I don't let me
tell you I couldn't agree more
let me tell you you're like you're the
concert MetLife Stadium you know all
that cheered songs even if it's bad how
could it even and he does have a good
voice and the this set the set list is
good and you know well of his songs and
you're sitting in a boxy you ticket
leader is sipping on wine how can it be
bad let me tell you thank you for asking
first of all it's a one-man show that's
what you need to understand there's
nobody else on stage which should be
super impressive like he is playing the
guitar he also plays like the drums he
like hits the guitar he is the pedal
yeah he's a little like such destiny
yeah so like he records his own
harmonies which is super cool and then
he also sings which is just a lot for
someone to do and it's a lot for someone
to do like at Madison Square Garden it's
a lie for someone to do at a stadium so
at a stadium it's like whoa you would
just expect a lot more like
production-wise and I almost like that
it wasn't production like like
pyrotechnics like I don't need that but
it's like he couldn't keep up with
himself and he was like singing like two
seconds behind his own music and me and
Margo were like looking at each other
and he was just like out of breath and
he was like he knew his songs are like
rap and they're fast and he like
couldn't keep up with his own music is
so weird and the crowd was like not
vibing at all and like it was so quiet
and literally you're at MetLife Stadium
like I could hear airplanes going into
Newark while he was singing like it was
so awkward and his banter between songs
was so like he was like coming off so
insecure he was like he did he does what
I do at my shows a south deprecation
yeah when you're putting on a shitty
show it's like I'm aware of how she
don't like when you're at Staton MetLife
Stadium like you need not be
self-deprecating like me and my like 20
person shows like it's funny for now but
like I mean also you are komak he is not
know and it was just like he was talking
about like the boyfriends and the super
dads like basically like dads that took
their daughters as chaperones and
boyfriends that came and he just like
couldn't supplementing on the people who
like didn't know his music do you know
any VA
good no it wasn't good and then like his
most popular song which is um shape of
you yeah but he said this before
something really 18 he's looking if you
don't know it like what are you doing
here like he was just so insecure about
the people like he couldn't get over it
it was so uncomfortable and like I don't
know I just
and for someone who like I really loved
his new album I didn't think he chose
good songs from the album to sing I
really wanted to like there was just so
much I wanted to hear and I felt like
the songs that he did sing he cut short
and then the songs that I didn't know he
literally sang like encores up like some
song from a cartoon he's on the
soundtrack of small like Lorax something
like the Lorax some they might but it
might not be that one but like it was a
10 minute song and I don't I'm not I
don't I don't think I just felt that way
because I didn't know the lyrics like
Margo knew the lyrics and she thought
the same thing so oh and the whole
concert was ruined because the girls
next to us there were two girls in the
box next to us it's not not girls lick
women who were black out screaming at
the top of their lungs but not like when
everyone was screaming like when it was
dead silent what she was most of the
time so it was like so extra and then
you think they're their biggest fans
like they didn't even know the words
like and then they were with this guy
who was like obviously I'd sheron's
number one fan but didn't scream like
cuz he was normal but he was being like
that person like singing like you know
[Music]
like in my ear in my ear this guy he had
a great voice was he in your box
he was in the box next to me but I was
sitting at the last seat in my bus and
he was sitting at the first in his box
got it do you have Goodfellow box
members um I don't know I didn't meet
anyone me tomorrow we're like in our own
world I understand um but it was just
like there were so many things and like
that it was disappointing that's all I
want to say and I'm afraid of what I
just said because like the EDS Dan is
very real because do you know I went
viral on Twitter last night no let me
show you I put up a video of Taylor
Swift just like harmonizing I actually
happened to see it I wasn't how music is
a video it was really good so I put it
up three thousand retweets twelve
thousand likes like and it's still going
but it's crazy to see once you go viral
for something Taylor Swift related um
the backlash and it's just like people
like are so mean to her and like for
literally no reason like but there are
like ed was doing this first but great
and loops himself he also sucks but now
they're gonna come for me
I was doing this first he doesn't talk
he I'll be there saying he invented like
that looping and harmonizing but she did
a really good job at it yeah did I say
she in bed today no I just said she was
good at it I can't deny Shan you can't
go viral these days
no but without further ado here are the
Fast Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay her story's a
two-parter but you have to wait for the
sound effect you like one two thoughts
no you went like that okay and that was
that oh I would like that okay this
first story is a two-parter because the
kardashian-west children were just
taking the world by storm the country by
storm this week Northwest made her
runway debut and Kim Kardashian was so
proud you guys if you haven't seen these
pictures and videos we have the picture
up on the stream right now but this
[ __ ] is so cute I can't precious looks
like Kim Kardashian's daughter Northwest
may be following in the footsteps of her
aunt's newest model kendall Jenner the
five-year-old child these are from ATP
on Saturday walking in the lol surprised
Nations show in Pacific Palisades near
Los Angeles the event celebrated the
launch of the toy brand's new bigger
surprise product North dressed up as the
lol surprise doll Thrilla Simone her
Uche styled the child whose characters
look it was inspired by Michael
Jackson's Thriller costume wearing a red
leather jacket and a matching miniskirt
a zip-up black crop top white socks
black shoes and a black Colt Jaya bag
that she stole from Claudia Austria and
red lipstick north made her way down the
catwalk as proud mama Kim looked on and
filmed her on her phone that bag is like
like four or five hundred I was like I
really I waited like a hanger it was I
was I was obsessed with that bag I like
looked everywhere for it I wanted to get
it on sale I did not want to pay full
price I ended up paying two ninety-eight
it was the last one at Bergdorf's and is
on sale and like literally Northwest
just like Charlotte about how was that
fair I mean she literally Sookie I mean
she got it for 298 also ever no but it's
like a bag that I a grown woman with a
job like lamented over for almost a year
you and Northwest that's that made you
really crazy like because you in this
scheme of like bags like I'm waiting for
my Gucci bag which is like way more
expensive than that and this was a bag
that you wanted for so long and it was
time I affordable actually and like
users they used to buy
because it's so trendy like it's and
it's also a beach bag like I'm never
gonna wear that bang City so like how
much can I feasibly spend on a bag that
will probably only last a couple years
and that I could only wear for like 30%
of said years yeah well you've been
wearing it a lot and I feel like this
just made it increase in value North
Carolina run good investment great
investment stock is rising and this was
just so cute we were talking about North
before the show like she's literally a
minicam like she's so obsessed like
beauty and fashion and like such a girly
girl and I feel like him is like so
proudly I feel like North wanted to walk
their own right and like Kim had to look
like Kim didn't make her do it no Kim
said that North wants to start her own
YouTube channel but like Kim obviously
won't let her cause she just monetize
the [ __ ] out of that first she has to
start her own YouTube channel like she
could be the beauty blogger that we've
all been waiting for
no no North West is something
something's coming no it's really true
like I know and like we thought it was
the kids supply Kim s to let that guy
North is the star North really is a big
big star did you want to see what she
does
no did you yes I was too busy catching
up on the trash that is re the one where
a season of all time who are these cast
members like it was that besides no one
pretty where Gabbana died but also
stormy was born
oh so it's it was like an end-of-life
full circle cyclical thing but it was
like it was really sad like the
Kardashians are weird about their dogs
cuz they're like always getting new dogs
and then they are never seen again like
remember
Kylie got a dog penny what happened to
the dog gnome and remember when Kylie
was hanging out with that dog that was
like fifty thousand dollars but it was
with the rolls yeah yeah two of them he
was like a leopard yeah bulldog yeah so
Gabbana has been consistent cuz they
were like the family dog when they lived
in that one full house and that episode
the Ranchero and that episode where
Kendall has to do all the chores and
then she find someone and hires him and
pays him $10 so I walked it on and stuff
and they were flashing back to all the
old clips but it's like the dog is lived
with everyone at some point of time like
they grew up with the family Kendall and
Kylie was like really their dog then
when Kendall and Kylie grew up he lived
with Kris and Bruce but then when Bruce
and Kris separated the dog lived with
Khloe and as lived with Khloe like
through the crack den Lamar Rob vibes
and since then and it's like Khloe was
saying was so sad she was like I feel
like Gabbana left me like now that I'm
about to have my baby like I don't need
her anymore and it was like so sad and
she was like I literally was crying the
whole time she was like my house is just
so quiet like and it was weird they like
got the dog in its last days like just
by
it seemed like Khloe and Kim were
sitting at the kids table eating their
salads from health-nut and Gabbana is
like whimpering and Kim like thinks
she's like having a heart attack but
Chloe's like this is just her life now
that's so sad I know dogs getting old
and like fat like makes me so sad and
dying oh my god I like want to kill
myself
it was a good episode because last
week's was not oh it wasn't um yeah it
was good uh
Kylie's like weird like is she in the
show is she not I don't know stormy was
on and they like June and see her just
saw her like wrapped in a thing but it
was interesting to see the whole labor
thing like Kourtney came into Kim's work
and I was like Kylie's in labor
and Kim was like what and they like
didn't go to the hospital they were like
Kim said that Kylie asked her to be like
the one in the delivery room with Kris
and Kim said I think Khloe should do it
which I want to understand the dynamic
you know right maybe because Khloe's
pregnant
I don't know like she could get some no
but also Khloe and Kylie I think are
closer and then Kim and Kylie it's the
weird part is what she asked why did
Kylie ask him maybe because Kim like has
had a bunch of babies yeah and
Kourtney's not like warm and loving so
you're gonna pick some one of the
mothers yeah okay and Kris Jenner Jason
just took Chloe shopping for baby stuff
and they were paying and Kris insisted
on paying for it and like she put her
card down like it was just so weird to
see like Kristin receipt like she
actually paid for it and like I feel
like any time they go to dinner anything
it's like fake right it was just it's
like about Kris Jenner has a credit card
in signs a receipt just like me you
decide me I wonder if she can write it
off cuz technically she's working yet
for sure no they definitely write off
their whole lives and it was the episode
was centered around Kourtney is now
fighting with Kris and basically was
saying some of the most [ __ ] up things
and was like my therapist really made me
realize like how terrible my childhood
was like I'm literally traumatized
she's like I'm literally traumatized
from like mom having an affair and like
I took dad's side and like that dad died
like she was basically talking about
like she literally grew up in a broken
home and it's like [ __ ] you grew up in
Calabasas with two rich parents but
ladies all they talk about is how their
childhood was so sublime and they want
to replicate that for their children
like how they grew up so close to each
other how their parents had such an
amicable divorce and that's look like
Kourtney almost is like modeling her own
life with Scott after that's such
[ __ ] you guys this [ __ ] this
therapist we need to report her to the
Medical Board so Kris
when she heard this Chris was like what
are you talking about you have it
literally the best childhood I forgot
what you call that she was like
fairytale like silver spoon like you
there was nothing wrong but like okay we
got divorced but like okay that's 50% of
America that's not you're not allowed to
use divorce as coming from a broken home
and also the only traumatizing thing
that you could claim is like the oj of
it all right and Chloe said Chloe said
Kourtney took Roberts side in the
divorce and in the trial because you
know Chris check the other side and took
the stand on behalf of her friend Nicole
Brown Simpson which was like the
honorable thing to do and whenever
people say that Kris Jenner is like a
mean [ __ ] up like Hollywood I'm like
no I'm sorry
she took the side of Nicole Brown
Simpson when nobody did accept her and
Faye Resnick and Connie Britton Blair
Chuck okay also more Kardashian West
news Kanye is a doting dad his son safe
there was the first pitch at the Chicago
baseball game these pictures are so cute
I'm gonna say something controversial
okay st. is the cutest kid I've thought
that ever since he was born
okay they're all really cute and they
all continue to get cuter but for me I
think North is the cutest because like I
love her spirit like her spirits shine
her spirit her spirit if only snitch was
here but she took the day off whatever
what nerve but her spirit shines through
I love her style and you know what I
feel like she makes a lot of her own
style choices I'm talking about purely
like looks aesthetic know for sure but
now like for me people's insights like
reflect their outside so I love North
and I just loved her personality and I'm
a girl's girl
Sam looks the most like Kanye he is
together as a human and honestly I never
remember if Chicago's a boy or girl
because it's such like an androgynous
like every word ambiguous
what's interactions mean both both words
but what does my uh androgynous is like
um just say you don't know I mean they
do know but I think it's like genderless
ready I'm gonna go to dictionary.com
that's what I'm always using the word
androgynous and I know I'm using it
incorrectly and I think I would like to
learn it and you know it's um infuse it
into my vocabulary okay
androgynous having both male and female
generalists okay um it's a genderless
name so I always forget if Chicago's boy
or girl I'm gonna win a baby so fresh
like they don't look like a boy or girl
there's look like a baby you know how I
remember whether she's a boy or girl Kim
had a
blossom themed baby shower which you
would only have a girl interesting just
remember that okay the cherry blossom
the cherry blossom baby shower that
Courtney didn't go to and Kim's new
cherry blossom collection is gorgina um
did you see she's uh falling into some
controversy because of the lipstick ad
to me she's wearing a lip ring and it's
like a very close-up picture of her lips
and her teeth and her grills and she's
like her and they're really similar to
this other lipstick line and that I had
never heard of but it has 300,000
followers and people are saying that can
copied well Kylie went through something
similar at the end of the day there is
only so many ways you can photograph a
set of lips like inspired by these
people but they always make it right
like she'll pay her and then she'll also
give her a promo on Instagram and at the
end of the day that girl is better off
for it so no but at the end of the day
like everyone copies it's like why
doesn't Kim just say like yeah I copy
dude I thought it was cool is it
why can't what what's wrong you just be
inspired by something put there and the
line is blurry and that's why I like Kim
stop making money like shouldn't copy
the product she copied the way that was
advertised like I don't know if you're
coming someone's shirt word-for-word
okay that's it then I agree but like if
you see a picture and it's like what's
wrong with just being like yeah I copy
did I thought it was cool for the people
were too embarrassed to say that but
like if I saw someone like putting a
cool picture of their lips with like a
lip ring and I copied it I wouldn't
pretend like it was my idea I'd be like
yeah I thought it was cool a copy right
but you're not like technically making
money I guess makes a business
whatevs anyway the whole Kardashian West
family is being really cute Kanye's
moving to Chicago is Kim I don't know
but like this is so giuliana rancic for
some reason it doesn't like worry me I
feel like they have a really good
situation except like the kids I guess
st. Joe's Chicago I mean yeah well no
it's the weekend and you could have just
been off from school that's what I feel
like Kim wouldn't let the kids be pulled
from school right it's like very Parent
Trap no one I just think that I think by
moving to Chicago means he's gonna like
have a house there and violas taxes
there like for a tax cut but we'll spend
probably like you know 120 days out of
the year in Calabasas very cool and
that's kind of like me and Cleveland
yeah
um did you hear oh you know much but
I've been trying to find a clip because
they were talking about like Chloe going
back to Cleveland and Chris was just
like I love Cleveland and I wanted to
make a me like Jackie no but like it's
true there's some
thing about I'm onto something here it's
like Cleveland it's just a simple life
if you're not onto it Chloe wasn't it
no no but like she was forcing it she
didn't choose Cleveland Trixie blue
chose her yeah Cleveland Cho sorry but
I'm choosing Cleveland just because I'm
putting together all of these socks and
like it seems like the city to be at
yeah
it's happening it's happening okay this
next story I just want to give like a
warning to you because I just want to
make sure you're gonna be okay
trigger warning a trigger warning Millie
Bobbie Brown gives epoch surprise
performance at maroon 5's concert Millie
Bobby Brown game room 5 fans the
ultimate surprise on Sunday when she
took the stage in the middle of their
national concert and performed their hit
girls like you the stranger things star
showed off her skills by wrapping the
lyrics normally performed by cardi B the
14 year old actress didn't seem to miss
a beat either the Bridgestone Arena
crowd went wild after her performance
and keep Adam Levine and Adam Levine
gave his stamp of approval by giving the
11 star high five
Brown posted a video of the memorable
moment on Instagram so tonight was
insane she captured the video what
so tonight wasn't saying she caption the
video
I loved at miranne 5 and my dear friend
at Adam Levine this is cool like I mean
she's living the dream and like
obviously I'm just jealous if it was
anyone other than her like I have been
the coolest it was Mason
Remy's and by the way that rap is
amazing and that song is so good and I
just like I'm glad that they didn't let
the moment go without like letting
someone come and perform it but like I
don't
when did Milli Bobby Brown become like
this thing this like darling and what
honestly like all the attention she's
getting from like older men is really
weird well he wanted to talk about the
Drake text message saga because people
are freaking out about it like and she
she mention it in passing she wasn't
trying to make it the story she was like
on a red carpet and like stopped by
Access Hollywood for two seconds and
they were talking about Drake and
basically what she said she's like we
text all the time yeah boy stuff tells
me that he misses me he's like I know
she's like I love him and now people are
dissecting so many things about Drake
because he was dating he is dating a
girl who's now a teen but apparently
been dating like since she was 16 and
there are some lyrics that are very
questionable um and this is weird and
now also like Odyssey Adam Levine is
smart he just gave her a high five cuz
like he knew what people were saying if
he gave her a hug like we would have
been done and that's just a disgusting
world that we live in but also like
Hollywood is disgusting so now I'm like
the Drake thing could have been
like innocent it's lovely like there
she's a nice girl like but do I really
think he's no but like Hollywood is so
[ __ ] disgusting and I'm never cease
to be amazed by how disgusting they are
like no this is weird it is I don't
follow
either of them and they've been having
like a courtship for a while of like a
thirsty internet friendship therefore I
refuse to give in to it
I definitely don't think that there's
like anything weird and I mean I don't
know Drake that well but I feel like
he's fine and if he wasn't even a sex
fiend right I do some of it the lyrics
that people are saying like are
questionable sure okay really about
ground hold on I don't know I okay you
have potential I could have shaped it
you went and caved in we could have
waited I wasn't rushing difference in
ages you're old enough but you're still
a baby you've shared stories where you
did amazing okay great in this in this
context bizarre yeah but like I don't
know it's hard with Italy by the ranks
we were just saying like yeah I was
saying to you like there's no way that
she's 12 turns out she's 14 but like she
really acts like she's 25 and so she
said she wanted the movie it's good she
also dresses like she's 75 so on the one
hand like drinks really talking to an
older woman right but then she's 14
know her brand is so confusing cuz like
that dress she wore to the Emmys his
letter to something like Helen Mirren
could have worn but then like - she
liked the Golden Globes last year she
wore like sparkly dress space bun and
sneakers and she was like I just want to
show everyone like you can wear sneakers
- in a word show like what you just
weren't how a mirrored dress it would
also like but you are 14 so that's
actually the appropriate thing to wear
right I don't know maybe I have more in
common with her than I thought because I
also dress like a child or grandmother
because there's no in-between with me I
just like um I don't want strange I
thinks like I never got hip - like why
people like her and that all I all I see
is like her having 17 million Instagram
followers and like everyone just like
immediately like loving her when like
what did she do
yeah I guess maybe what about the other
kids that kid with no teeth is so much
cuter yeah and all those kids get that
right or the girl that looks like you
who this stranger thinks girl the right
Atta girl
I don't know her she's cute nice to see
her no one cares about her strange barb
yeah people care about her but look
nobody cares what the other kids and
they're cute - right I don't know I just
like she doesn't do it for me and like
all these like it's like I feel like she
really just wants me like Internet viral
famous FaceTime
Maison Ramsey and now like she's like
things went sour no no not really it's
worked no but like now things that
people are putting this in a negative
light and I actually really don't think
there's anything wrong with her a text
saying no but there's nothing wrong with
her
no it's like Hollywood's discussing now
they're all siting like old things that
like of your ended but I'm just like her
I'm not even concerned with like the
drag thing like I don't think there's a
problem there like hopefully her parents
are somewhat involved in her life and
she'll be fine but you never know
it's just like hurt that bothers me and
it's like why why do you get to like go
to the Emmys and where I'm Helen Mirren
dressed but then also like day Jacob
Sartorius and like maybe have sex with
him we don't know we don't we definitely
don't know she I can't have sex with
anyone under 18 but can two 14 year olds
have said yes okay I believe that that
makes sense right oh I don't know anyway
she performance maroon 5 her mic goes
off for the first half oh yes it's like
she did a good job though no she like
loves to remember that's how it all
started do you remember that's how she
became the thing that she is on Jimmy
Fallon she rapped Nicki Minaj's song
monster okay and everyone died it
literally has 50 million views on
YouTube and like that's what started her
dissension into thirst monster fame
got it so now she's like has a rap
career as well right she's a pretty good
rapper she knew the words I don't think
that's that's half the game she did a
pretty good job she was like heated
about it it's just like I mean that
would be like my dream right like not
like being famous for like being a comic
but then like be anybody don't say it's
just sitting right it's like Jennifer
Lawrence like you're a claimed actress
but then like you're on watch I have
inside with Jackson right exactly
mother Ross over yeah Jennifer Lawrence
was in my dream that she commented on my
Instagram what she doesn't even have an
instant right but she made one and
commented she made one just so she could
accomplish she was new to Instagram and
then she commented on mine and she's
like a grandma using the microwave ya
know it was really weird actually it was
a weird dream um next story now into
business news because this is the most
business savvy show on TV
Weight Watchers it's changing its name
to ww-wait Watchers really wants to let
you know that it's not just a diet
company so much so that it's changing
its name to WW here is the war on diet
the company announced Monday that the
new WWE reflects its overall reflects
its focus on overall health and wellness
and not just shedding pounds CEO Mindy
Grossman said in a statement that the
company remains quote committed to
always being the best weight management
program on the planet but that it wants
people to also focus on eating healthy
exercising and having a more positive
mindset Oprah Winfrey who was a member
of the company's board and owns more
than a percent stake echoed these
comments the role WW can play in
people's lives goes far beyond a number
on the scale as Weight Watchers becomes
WW I believe we will continue to inspire
people not only to eat well but to move
more connect with others and continue to
experience the joys of a healthy life
says Oprah Winfrey okay like this is
this is really like the war on the first
of a straws and now it's done the word
diet and just like the whole like even
the biggest diet company in the world is
not even calling themselves dieting
anymore like and look if I if I am
saying like I'm someone who's so anti
dieting like just do whatever you want
it's like I'm so not here for this war
on dieting like Weight Watchers is a
company actually the only diet I've ever
had success with in like the past five
or ten years is Weight Watchers yes it
really really works like and you get to
maintain like a healthy balance of like
you can still eat like crap if you want
you just have to eat a lot less of it so
if you want to eat a lot of food eat
like you can like they have like weight
watchers points out like Applebee's so
if you can still go to all your favorite
restaurants you don't see change your
life that much but like then you just
make better choices right and they have
the best string cheese on the market so
it's just like it really is like a good
healthy diet that like people live on
like after you it's a lifestyle it is
like I guess is what they're trying to
say but it's like I feel like the war on
undying it has only started to creep up
and I feel like Weight Watchers making
this move it's like they're ready
they've given it in their speedy yeah
yeah and it's like the we didn't even
wage war yet no and it's like if you get
to your goal weight on Weight Watchers
they give you a free lifetime membership
so you can live your life and maintain
your weight and it's so cute on Weight
Watchers and I went to a Weight Watchers
meeting once and it was literally like
ninety year old women there who have
been on it for 50 years
also there's nothing wrong with saying
that you're watching your weight and all
of these things that they're trying to
accomplish with the new WW still fall
under the umbrella of watching your
weight you know and also all the things
that the drink of WW that you were doing
as weight watchers right so it's just
like a PR movement to appease like the
five people who have their blog us in a
twist yeah
about dieting yeah and I don't like it I
don't like this caving to the peer
pressure I don't like it either but you
know Oprah's you always have to do
what's right she's a good woman but he
said no one asked her you
yeah she's so rich does that was a great
investment for I love cuz she puts
ourselves into all the commercials no um
yeah I'm pro wait like I like Weight
Watchers I'm gonna continue to call it
what you actors by the way because WWE
were off the time not at all it's it's
literally two letters but it takes so
much more to say than Weight Watchers
they should have changed it to something
that was like another acronym no uh
alliteration with w w but like if you
didn't want to be Weight Watchers it
could be like we work you know like I
don't know I bet you leave it to the
branding experts yeah they're trying
like a little just this is like a little
too much for me yeah I'm not here too
much too soon and like oh my god like so
are we go are we moving towards a world
where like no diets exist I mean I'm not
like either I'm totally misunderstanding
this whole conversation which I don't
think that I am or everyone's out of
control
I believe that everyone's out of control
and I feel like people don't even feel
this way I feel like there's a select
few people like with a lot of power and
like a big Twitter who are waging the
war on dieting but nobody agrees it but
because these big people are saying it
like you think everyone agrees with it
but like they're just like we're the
silent majority also I'm confused
because I refused to be son because I'm
the one hand like America's obese and
like we all need to lose weight and
we're the fattest country in the world
on the other hand were not allowed to go
on a diet so like you know what do you
what do you want from us you know we
would love to hear from Michelle Obama
agreed she really liked has a huge
advocate of childhood obesity so does
she agree with I'm sorry
so yeah I forget again celebrate and
like fighting fighting childhood obesity
so I wonder if she is on board for the
war on diets I don't think so does this
mean they're gonna go back to putting
like all that junk food in schools and
go to undo all of the work that she did
this is because events everything
Michelle Obama Bluestone it's true where
is she we got to talk to her I don't
know maybe she said like it's just it's
alright I shan't and I will always I
live my whole life on a diet up until
this point even when I'm not dying
dieting I'm dieting and I haven't and we
agree right you know I go to opposite
sides of spectrum right I don't believe
in dieting
I don't care and I and we agree we see
each other
Jynx that has become my absolute
favorite thing to say
because it's it means it says so much
with saying so little and it's so it
like you could say it anywhere and it
would make sense yeah I forgot who I was
talking to I don't know but it's like we
see in a canoe with a hand lotion
where's we see each other
okay next story from The Wall Street
Journal no sex please were Apple iPhones
giant Sikhs TV success on its own terms
the tech giant Apple wants to make
scripted shows for streaming only
without violence politics and risque
storylines so like PG as hell Tim Cook
sat down more than a year ago to watch
Apple Inc's first scripted drama vital
signs and was troubled by what he saw
the show a dark semi-biographical tale
of hip-hop artist dr. Dre featured
characters doing lines of cocaine and
extended orgy in a mansion and drawn
guns sir watch a show it was too violent
for mr. cook and I don't have a wall
street journal subscription so I can't
read the rest of the story however in
turn Apple is focusing on non violent
non criminal non lewd programming for
what for Apple to like they're gonna
start their own streaming service like
Netflix and do original programming but
without rated R well so I feel torn here
because I really do love the whole
concept of leaving politics out of
entertainment and if you like you letter
can't watch any show these days without
someone pushing some sort of an agenda
and it's so annoying until I have your
horse blinders on so I'd like that but
like without violence or sex like what
I'm gonna talk about I don't know maybe
it's like the new Disney right but is if
we're gonna be for kids I don't know I
could go for a new deal and then where
do you draw the line at sex like are
there gonna be couples like I can get a
kiss like yes for sure for sure but if
they're definitely no sex scene no hand
jobs under the D ball no like maybe
they'll they'll allude to it but you
won't see it okay I'm trying to show
that I watch that's like isn't political
sexual or violent right I feel like
there are some ABC shows yeah like
Modern Family perfect so like that I
mean I guess someone could argue no I'm
not gonna say that I'm not gonna give
those bigots a voice no I mean I watch
reality so like that's not political at
all but it's no resection or imaginary
violet depending on what network right
and very like lewd with cursing like I
yeah just to bring it back - are you the
one like literally they are making sex
tapes it's so I was
literally watching a sex date last night
well yeah but like the fact that MTV
airs that like when we used to watch
Jersey Shore like they would go a little
far and like put the audio of like the
moans and stuff and like you would see
like a figure under a sheet like moving
but it's gotten so crazy no I watched
two people like have sex in the shower
and I while I didn't see like genitalia
I saw everything else so when I made a
funny joke about ww-what World War three
on diets oh my god that's good that's
good you guys movie gives everything so
Naomi there have been so many World War
three's totally straws plastic in
general no but since 1945 everything
else has been in World War three
you know if there was an actual board
war it would have to be like number
eight right and also like any time
siblings fight its World War three
totally but also let's not let's not
hurt let's pray for no world war that's
that's not encourage a third world we
were watched one of the funniest
episodes of curd last night and you know
I'm always doing this and they had a
whole part on this because spoiler alert
Larry hired a probably guess
investigator and found out he's adopted
so he goes to our zone so funny and he
finds that he's like I'm not in June
yeah because he walks into his birth
parents house and there's like a picture
of Jesus on a big cross and he's like
I'm a Gentile so he gets into Gentile
culture like wears cargo shorts and goes
to church and we're sweater vests and it
is so funny it is so funny and then the
episode ended weirdly where he died
right
that was weird that was weird it's a
weird time yeah but then he came back I
don't know it's a weird time no that's a
hilarious episode and so Gentile culture
and by late so june squibs plays his mom
and also like that episode represents
like the our story of being not in truth
what's necessary like man chuck it was
Gentile culture we did not fit in and
that's how we got to not in tune with
what's necessary Larry's parents are
doing grace before their meal and then
they finish the grace and she's like any
asks or what that is and he was doing it
and like that I'm like that's you you're
Larry okay there's an final story before
we just talk more nonsense and giddy
dear toasters Sirius XM is buying
Pandora in a three point five billion
dollar deal okay that seems overvalued I
don't know anyone over the age of 97 who
has used Pandora yes re under well a
budget joke Sirius XM is buying Pandora
and a 3.5 billion all-stock deal the
deal will create the world's largest
audio entertainment company the company
said
or Monday SiriusXM has 36 million
subscribers in North America it was
formed with the merger of the Sirius and
XM satellite radio services in 2008
Sirius have paid Howard Stern the
hundreds of millions of dollars to learn
him from traditional radio in 2006
Sirius XM has built a stable of stars
with exclusive programming to go along
with its line of music news talk and
sports Pandora a groundbreaking
streaming music service founded in 2000
and never evolved past that has more
than 70 million active users so what
holoband make a wish get you bad it
faces intense competition from Spotify
for music services offered by Apple
Amazon and jay-z's title barely but it
doesn't offer competition because
they're not even in the same like Lane I
know but technically like if you want to
listen to music you either go to Spotify
Apple Pandora know you don't know but
that sounds like you don't have you
literally just go to Spotify or Apple
music or YouTube if you like join the
subscription right Pandora's ability to
stay an independent company was very
much in doubt Sirius XM had already
invested 480 million to buy 19 percent
of Pandora's stock last year and was
widely reported to be looking for a full
purchase that purchase has happened I
just feel like this is another example
of Sirius XM it's like not at all in
tune with what's going on in the world
you think my sound
first of all in no way could anyone
argue that this is a good investment I
would not have spent more than like
realistically like five hundred million
dollars on Pandora as a company like yes
they had a bunch of users like ten years
ago
technically they're counting me as one
of the 70 million users but I don't know
my login and my last like updated
playlist is Kesha Kesha Kesha
so like unless there's some big secret I
don't know going on a Pandora like they
own the patent to some [ __ ] this is just
a terrible investment I feel like every
time I've either like been to Sirius had
any experience with serious or just like
hearing news about them like they're
always making bad decisions like and
they're known notoriously for like
literally paying their female hosts like
nothing yeah oh yeah the most
paid Sirius XM host is Jenny McCarthy
because she is the biggest audience
female
sorry yeah and homegirl makes like 250
grand from that show where's like Howard
Stern maybe hundreds of million and yes
he definitely is way more viewers but
like come on and he came over with like
he never learn him but like radio and do
you let his he do watch ever your hair
on your mic
I don't know but that like them giving
radio and II like a station isn't you Oh
totally but like I just feel like you're
gonna evolve like they don't they don't
I don't know like it's so hard to watch
I mean as someone who doesn't Drive I
wouldn't even know how to begin to use a
Sirius XM a subscription yeah like no
the car has to come with satellite radio
or else somehow yeah but I don't even if
I don't have a car can you listen to it
otherwise yeah you can listen to it
online like Serena
oh yeah I but you have to make you have
to subscribe so you to pay every month
or something and that's how they make
money
whatever all I'm saying is like they're
just not into like I feel like honestly
like it's really backwards model and
like they're so anti podcasts which is
the dumbest thing you can do as an audio
company because like whether you like it
or not podcasts or the future and then
audio more people are listening to
podcast than are listening to radio
sorry and like they're just so against
it like they should like produce podcast
and they should have all their high
talent like been doing podcasts or like
they should honestly they should hire us
like their the fact that I've never even
heard from them is why they're not right
that they're not even our Raider of like
podcast company like audio companies
that you would want to work with right
like we are actively we're on Spotify
now we're on stitcher we're on cast box
we're on iTunes we're on soundcloud like
and places I'm trying to get like I
haven't even like no but my desk has not
been crossed no and it won't because
it's a whole other model where like
people have to pay would have to pay
there to listen to us when they can get
it for free why would they totally I
don't know man I hope these two
dinosaurs find love together serious and
Pandora that's like a huge mistake
honestly that's like someone paying
three billion dollars like not to be
mean but like to buy AOL oh you're gonna
say and that's a I Heart Radio that that
would be the same thing but I our radio
gets a little credit for their semblance
of relevance in terms of podcasts they
do kill it now I our radio awards and
festivals and them just like hiring
people from The Bachelor like you know
what they're at least trying to be for
sure with those things make no money if
in fact they lose them how much are my
money a very much strictly relevance
okay like yeah they're there do need a
job in the relevant yes AOL makes money
because like people forgot that they put
credit cards down 10 years ago to make
an email like that's not real money who
are still on Pandora yeah honestly a
well should've bought Pandora no totally
and then they can both like Spotify it's
just truly everything to me everything
to me I
I spy defied leaves me leading nothing
except it leaves me needing one little
thing the 1989 World Tour is only
available on Apple music and like in
three blurry parks on YouTube my spot
that's Taylors Falls no yeah I know I'm
by the right now the Taylor's back onto
modified like there's really nothing I'm
missing except Garth Brooks but like I
only like really one of his songs the
only thing I'm missing from Spotify that
like I said that I wish I had is not
even Spotify fault I wish Spotify was
around earlier because I had used to
like I want to see the music that I used
to listen to like ten years ago I used
to have like really great iTunes
playlists and like my I want to see what
my most listened to songs were yeah and
I don't know how to get that information
also I feel like before spot if I got
really popping we were on it and they
used to have that start feature which
was like the best feature I've been
literally one day they like took it away
and it was the best feature and it made
no sense but now they have the plus
feature which I use for everything
that's how I make my playlists but you
can't share your you're saved like ice
not really a playlist it's not a play
looks like I can't send it you and
that's frustrating no I still use the
starred feature except you have to
right-click and I start swiping and
clapping just used to tap the star and
then it would show up it was so genius
and that was like my favorite part and
really what drew me to Spotify yeah and
literally like a couple months in it
just disappeared it was so weird
yeah they got rid of their best thing
yeah I had one more qualms with Spotify
but it's minor and I already forgot it
that's how minuscule no another at their
podcast so like except to have you
ordered anything about Amy Schumer's
podcast um I don't know I think I asked
Danis her biggest dance and really
listened to it I think I forget what she
said so it couldn't have been that
memorable but I don't think it was that
great and I don't think Amy like Amy's
one of four people like it's not really
her podcast right so like but it's
branded obviously it's like dang machine
we're podcast and she got paid like a
million dollars to do like 10 episodes
it's exclusive to Spotify and except she
said something really funny that Dana
said she was like so we're starting a
podcast because like we heard you can
just make a [ __ ] ton of money but like
there was a thread in the toasters about
it and I feel like the toasters are
really like the ideal pot there they are
podcasters like yeah they're who the Amy
Schumer show was developed for like they
like comedy they like pop culture they
like Amy Schumer they like podcasts so I
feel like they're like the perfect focus
group of people who should have liked it
and they all had just negative things to
say they're like obviously she only did
it because they paid her a million
dollars and like wouldn't you sit down
for a couple hours for a million dollars
and the
heart wasn't really in it and they were
just like it was so bad Wow and I just
found that so interesting it's like when
you try to make podcasts podcasts can't
be bought
you know what I mean oh and there are
podcasts that exists like celebrity
podcasts just to fill 10 minutes at a
time in between ads like they're built
around ads and they like it's like they
have the ads and now we have to make a
show when it's like it should be the
exact opposite of that right and you can
feel when it is like that like okay we
have to get to 40 minutes so that we can
sell for adblocks yeah and we can make
this money but you know they really
don't have anything to say now they're
just talking you know who is a celebrity
podcast that I've actually never
listened to but has like a rave reviews
is Anna Faris's unqualified like she's
not just filling time slots between she
doesn't need a podcast like but I think
that it's really successful it is really
people really like it I remember one
time when I was just like so bored at
work I like wanted to listen to an
episode she maybe have like she had
someone on who I really liked maybe was
like having a heart or something she
gets recast and I didn't make it past
the first few minutes there was like a
baby crying in the back yeah I think
it's like part of the like this shtick
there was like multiple hosts and I was
like mmm no also Jack Shepard house 1
and it's always at the top of the the
charts because like Kristen Bell treats
it out like it's not good it's not I
don't know I never watched him just
jealous yeah the only podcast I ever
really listened to and enjoyed was
actually there was one straight up with
Stassi he's so nice intuitive episode
with Emma Roberts is the cutest thing of
all time totally - it doesn't exist
anymore but Grantland which like is no
longer even a company is like a sports
podcast so you said to people who did a
Bachelor podcast but they would talk
about it like sports like do Power
Rankings and they also used to film and
I used to watch it as a video and it was
so funny there was like one guy I think
his name like David Jacobi or something
askew he was cute and he was just so
funny I think we could just like talk
about The Bachelor and such a funny way
and it got me like way more into The
Bachelor right I don't know I just I
feel like I prefer to watch something
than listen to something because if you
listen it's like you can do other things
and like I'm just a type of person like
if I'm doing a million things like I'm
not listening I'm like doing something
else you know right but that's why the
morning toast is all of the above
because we've hit all your names yeah
and like you live your life the way you
live in we're not gonna tell you how to
watch us yeah except you should move
over to YouTube from Facebook yeah but I
did used to listen to stassi's as well
it was good yeah
it is good yes sir she it is good she's
great okay we haven't done to your
toasters in so long and
design and you chose movie of the week
did he ever talk about the polka you
know it wasn't well-received like no no
one I don't think anyone watching no
they did there was a thread about it do
they like it so a lot of girls watched
it with their boyfriends fiance's and
they said at first when the thread went
up it was like immediate hey why they
sign why did they sign and then a bunch
of girl one girl was like I'm afraid to
say like me and my fiance loved it we
actually watch it again and then another
girl was like girls who watched it with
their boyfriends fiancees husbands loved
it and girls should watch it alone or
with other girlfriends did it like that
it's so funny cuz we had the exact
opposite experience we watched it with
our family just the girls and we loved
it
then we were like to our fiance's
husbands you guys have to watch this
you're gonna loved it we'll watch it
together we all watched you to get there
in Turkey goes and they hated it and
they wouldn't I'm making fun of the
whole time and they like made me
question my my love for you and like my
taste and it's not even I like watching
I was like oh my god I love this movie I
was like oh my god what did I just watch
like it was just I came to this is a
true story that what people said was
like honestly when we found out it was a
true story at the anime the whole movie
worth it cuz like yeah if it wasn't a
true story I'm just been doing a really
weird thing to make a movie about but
because it is a true story it's such an
interesting thing to make a movie about
lets me remind you the truth movie of
the week is supposed to spark an
interesting conversation which I think
this movie effectively did we're not
saying we're recommending the greatest
every movie I'm not gonna recommend
great is showing that we're recommending
stories that teach you something that
make you have interesting conversations
you learn a little something
you'll research you'll have a
conversation like I just think that was
great and I loved to see Jack Black play
something other than like a silly guy he
was so funny and so cute in it and like
yon LaVon he's a legit like so he was so
pure like all he wanted to do was like
make polka mucus music and pay his
people decent wages right and that
that's really like the trajectory until
he gets to a point where it's like he's
not pure anymore and that's how he
that's what is his downfall
and what's so crazy is that his downfall
is the pageant like he's his whole Ponzi
scheme unraveled because he has I rigged
a pack because his [ __ ] is what was so
annoying and then she leaves him oh my
god she was the widow but he did
everything for her oh my god I can't I
couldn't like she was bothering me so
much like obviously she wasn't good ways
you couldn't do anything like she wasn't
are the other girls were still ways were
qualified in the pageant right and like
she was out of the pageant for so long
and she like was at the dry cleaners and
she didn't like being mrs.
Livan like that's what made her not like
d alter what chameleon like being at the
Grammys on his arm like are you kidding
me like that you have the Grammys and ya
know and that carbon like she would
argue to her mom that he has this great
husband
but then when society deemed her her
husband's wife she was upset you know
right and contradicted get back into the
path became which she obviously had to
ring because she had no chance of
winning and he just wanted to hurt us
fulfill her dreams and then she leaves
him at the end also he gets shanked in
prison you know like like that really
happened the movie was was good Jack
Black was excellent and like I just
loved I loved him he did such a good job
like I just thought it was so
interesting to see him play like
something the polar opposite of what
he's played forever a historical figure
and do it really well and what's so
crazy is at the end they tell you how
much money he stole from like he stole
millions of dollars from people 40
million I think and like firm people in
like over 48 states around the country
like this thing went national from their
little polka town yeah in New Jersey and
I did something I just think I think
it's a great toast movie of the week
because it accomplishes what we set out
but I think toast movie of the week has
gotten misconstrued by some people
thinking it's like let's what's the best
musical or rom-com right no no we're
talking about you watch it anyway I want
to expand my horizons a little bit I
want to learn something I want I watch
the same garbage all the time and I like
it's just useless and I'm just like on
my phone and time passes like I want to
be intrigued and I want to be kept on
the edge of my seat and that was done by
the Polka king great let's assign our
next movie what's on the list
oh let me pull up my I want another true
story like the founders the definition
do we do that already yes okay hold on
um
is the definition of what the toast
movie of the week should be something
interesting a story you would never know
otherwise a true story ideally okay I
don't have any more my last thought was
that you don't yeah well we'll think
about think about it and go back okay
cool
definitely true story maybe like a war
movie Oh have you seen war dogs no
Jonah Hill my of course is so good yeah
another true wild sir but I feel like
everyone's seen that and it was
popularize miles how isn't it yeah so
like tree man how could you not watch oh
there are a couple miles towers we need
that are new that I didn't see thank you
for your service that one have you seen
it no let's do it okay and you know what
else I want to do 13 hours um no oh my
god that gives me such a bit
Goti because it's on demand now it's
Randall I might select the Lyle account
of it we do the story
let's do the miles teller why okay thank
you for your service miles teller next
week hopefully hopefully it's a long
week oh by the way it's programming
updates tomorrow's episode of the
morning toast is going to be podcast
only because Claudia's hitting the road
going to DC all three shows are sold out
sorry I can't do anything for you
Wednesday's episode will Wednesday or
Thursday one of them will be with Ben
soccer I don't know if you've heard of
him boys no job he's Claudia's husband
he's so weird find our videos popular
Coco's she's our most popular cut
everyone demands Sam all of his videos
have the most views and I'm like I don't
even understand he's not that good
nobody gonna he's great I like he makes
it easy for me but like everybody's
great like what what about what is it
about Ben you know I don't know maybe
just like the familial and aspect also
like maybe just having the perspective
that's like really he disagrees me on
everything not because he actually feels
that way but just because he wants to be
contrarian right and also like you and I
pretty much agree on everything so if
there's someone like watching on home
feeling like a go shouting at us that
we're wrong like Ben sort of like tastes
the other side most of the time yeah
that meme is so funny
the ghosts mean ya know the ghost of
Tabriz Pat okay so I pulled up some tier
toasters and then the other Wednesday
Thursday will be someone else so stay
tuned
dear toasters so even under twisters in
a while as you guys know or if you're
new to the show do your toasters is our
advice segment where we talk about you
know any of your problems you email dear
toasters at gmail.com it's all anonymous
if you have any questions we do a lot of
like wedding relationship family stuff
but we've been changing it up because
that was getting a little stale and last
week we had some great ones and this
week we have some great ones too I
really pulled like the weird ones out
this one is and I didn't read them
thoroughly through because I was in a
rush this morning so we'll say my water
matches maybe this is from Aunt Mickey
fascinated hello to my fearless leaders
Thank You Becky um her name wasn't
actually thinking no no but she tended
to aunt Vicki because it's about being
an aunt oh my god oh I have the most
expertise here I am an aunt Vicki - a
lovely three-year-old girl who has - who
was blessed with two mommies my sister
has a lesbian
we were watching a cartoon together the
other day and she began to cry because
the little girl in the cartoon had a mom
and a dad which is obviously common when
watching all these shows she has two
very loving mothers but obviously she's
aware that she's different than the
majority of families no matter how
episodes of Modern Family she watches
her mom's we're not around when this
happened and I really didn't know how to
handle it so my questions are do I tell
my sister that had happened I don't want
her to be upset - how do you think I
should handle it if it happens again
thank you love you long time
wow that's tough I think you don't ever
like we didn't grow up in a family that
had two moms like you don't ever think
about like how kids react to just like
television yeah
would you supposed to be like a
reflection of their own life like in
room like hey everything he knew about
the world was from television right and
that really does like set the mindset or
next movie do mean I'll do it no and I
haven't seen it yet you have in know
someone I have to watch it I have a pain
in my stomach okay let's do that first
okay but I have to write down I can't
watch it until Jack gets back from his
business trip okay what was the other
one um thank you for your service and
what was one we were gonna do after that
um 30 Gotti Gotti and 13 hours it's good
- okay so officially we're gonna do room
because I really I've been meaning to
talk about it since I watched it on the
plane and cuz Jacob Tremblay obviously
do room I'm gonna make you watch wonder
no no no no then we can't watch room I
really can't watch wonder like I would
know we have to do room no I really what
I can okay back to antiquing um I
thought I would have to so much
expertise on this because I am an honest
number one but I would say my advice
would be definitely tell your sister
Nina she should know what any shouldn't
come out like that's a very natural way
for it to come out in the daughter and
so now she knows and like so the next
time something happens like she's more
prepared as opposed to letting it fester
and like if no one addresses it maybe
she'll feet like the child like feel
like people are hiding something from
her so I would just tell your sister and
let her deal with it in the way that she
sees fit yeah like it's you Junius aunt
just to deliver the information but
since you're not a mom you know you
don't not burdened with this problem
right I'm sure they assume that this
might happen one day something right
they are more equipped than you know
yeah they just hit it over yeah if
something happened at my home with you
like I would just tell you would you
yeah okay unless it was my fault
Yeah right no but this wasn't know um so
next year toasters no no I had something
else to say about the movies you know so
interesting is like I watch modern
family as like just a patron of the Arts
but it really does like it is the only
show on TV that like represents the
modern family yeah you know and I guess
I mean realize that more now
like and also some shows have like
aspects of a modern family like I'm
glean Lea Michele oh yeah like this is
almost like a joke and like they never
showed the dads except once and it was
played by Jeffrey that guy who was a
statue of himself
do you see that no Jeffrey something
he's an old Goldblum Oh Jeff Goldblum
yeah yeah please her dad what he's funny
no but I at Modern Family like there's
so many different representations of
families like so many like divorce
parent parents who like now have a
younger wife and like the wife is older
than them
yeah epidemic the air and foster David
Foster right and like I guess like I've
only watched it as an adult but like
kids who watch it like feel represented
by it that's great yeah I guess I saw
the call it's modern it's been like ABCs
like mission mission like so they have
the Goldbergs which is like suppose
representing Jewish family oh yeah like
some of the characters are well I like I
love Wendy but like she's not Jewish
she's not a Jewish mom no Jewish moms
are not like that like she could like
why didn't they cast Jews that's weird
Jeff Garlin is Jewish is he he's also
from kirb I love him he's my favorite
actor um
but why didn't they cast all Jews and I
think Barry is Jewish yeah I met him
once
did you at a party we were at a party
what and I was like no but agent
Michelle was like well it was a cool
party in Brooklyn and no one there knew
who he was on a roof right no he's in a
backyard
what are you outside and I didn't know
like I like I had no business being
there and being a Goldberg fan you know
right right right no but it's not right
they didn't care for anyone Jewish right
and like the daughter is definitely not
just and she's from X Factor did you
know that the singing Cho yeah the DA
she was like did I make it you have
placing a group and like they had like
literally they made it like one more
round and then she was like instagrammy
and then she's on the Berg's
good for her she's better off yeah also
like then they had fresh off the boat
which I used to watch all the time but I
really couldn't keep up with the week to
week and it was very controversial fresh
off the boat was it yeah did you not
hear well the title fresh off the boat
is like a condescending
phrase towards immigrants so people were
already not happy with it but it was
based on any-quan' site raisin that the
name of the book the book yes and it's
supposed to be like this irreverent like
show it's so funny yeah no people were
not happy with it oh gosh it's not on
anymore no I think it is I just couldn't
like keep up wait to make I'm not gonna
like liqueur and then it also had a show
of like
white Irish they'd Lex yeah it was not
popular oh I think I remember and then
also blackish yeah so like they're doing
a good job and they also and then
Bacchus has a spin-off on freeform now
grown ashram with francia raisa that's
really cute I don't gave Selena Gomez
her kidney and only first date that
Selena Gomez to continue to do drugs and
abuse the kidney I wonder if they still
talk I thought that they don't I want to
check up Selena Gomez still falls short
Instagram if I was French yeah right you
suck I mean like so angry even if
they're not friends she still follows
her because like Selena would never do
anything till I'd show people like the
true her eye like there's a only post
for you oh she does follow France yeah
okay
I mean and Francie is gonna be in
life-size too also I heard some
interesting tea on Selena Gomez cuz like
the thing with the blinds is like what
what they say that Selena in the vines
is that like she is just like can't stop
during judge she's like a functioning
drug addict and like literally she is
weekend at Bernie's her team drops her
up when she needs to and then she's like
in her den doing crack um but like the
blinds are so outrageous sometimes like
really like I feel like sometimes I
can't believe it
so would this Lily anything it's like I
see the lens of like her being a cracker
but I also see like maybe she's not you
know but then I got some okay you know
and I was like maybe she's not you know
out here like slaying her name but I got
some good tea last week that confirms
that it's someone who knows like a lot
of local law enforcement where Selena
lives and they say they're called to her
house all the time and she like she
doesn't go to the hospital like [ __ ]
like they'll they'll just as narcan but
it's like if someone overdoses even if
they survive they go to the hospital but
like no she'll like just wake up and
like stop like live that's so crazy I
know um I'll be ready for next year
toasters yeah this one is called they
get weirder and weirder so I'm sorry to
everyone there's one is called boyfriend
masturbates in his sleep okay this one
was particularly interesting to me right
to your Claudia and Jackie you guys said
you wanted more diverse questions and
less bachelor wedding girl questions so
here it is please keep my name anonymous
I have a lot of friends who are jesters
and I would rather to stay anonymous I
understand my boyfriend and I've been
dating almost a year and we spend the
night we spend the night with each other
almost yeah this is a block yeah one
night I woke up to what I thought was
him twitching or scratching an itch when
I open my eyes I could see
jerking off and masturbating in his
sleep his head was in his pants and he
was going at it he was still completely
asleep I didn't know what to do so I
just lay there and observe for a minute
before finally gently kink again this
seemed to partially wake him up and he
stopped and fell back asleep this happen
about three times now and each time he's
completely asleep almost like he is
sleepwalking but like touching himself
it's kind of freaky when I wake up in
the middle of the night to do it what do
I do
do I mention it to him in a loving way
explain to him when I observe or just
let him go and never mention it I love
him unconditionally and this would never
determine away from him but I'm worried
he might be embarrassed by bringing up
and I don't want to make it a big deal
please let me know your thoughts PS when
will you be accepting new members space
Book Group I've been a morning joe /
proud listener for over a year
let's Ruben I was about to make an
announcement about the Facebook group
I've been like doing membership all
weekend and the questions are in a good
place where like their opinion based and
I'm judging your answers so request now
and if you you need to re-request like
even if you've requested two weeks ago
request again with new Answers and I'll
be doing it all day today so today's
your chance and if you don't get it it's
because your answers are mad so I chose
this one because it hit home yeah
because I don't know if I mentioned it
something you have not I am NOT and Ben
is going to kill me but they got he
doesn't watch a show but Ben is a sleep
sexer so it's like literally it started
maybe two years ago whereas like I would
like feel something in my sleep in bed
with like literally me trying to like
kiss me and I would like shake him and
wake him up what are you doing
I need me just go back to sleep and then
in the morning I'd be like oh my god
like what did you do last night and he
was like what do you mean
I need like he thought I was lying a
hundred times I mean it would drive me
mad like I would wake up in the middle
that I in bed would be trying like hug
and kiss me and I would like to shake
him and he would go back to sleep so
then need to put a CO cam in there wait
then I when he start to like did not
like say that I was lying
it started to bother me so he did it I
would like to shake him wake him up so
hard make him stay up for like ten
minutes
till he's fully awake and then he'd be
like you did it then he started to
believe me it's gotten to the point now
where I can almost anticipate been in my
sleep I sometimes on the weekends I wake
up with my bra unhooked which is the
most annoying uncomfortable feeling
people are gonna be like why are you
sleeping with a bra oh because I want to
leave me alone that's really it's gotten
into the point where it's been is in his
sleep
I can anticipate in my sleep I
anticipate him getting up and coming
over to me and I'll literally in my
sleep shoot up and push him off and I
told him about it he there's I don't
know what we could do there's nothing we
can do that is so interesting well to
this girl I would definitely tell him I
don't think he'll embarrass maybe like
men are not embarrassed about that like
yeah but I don't think it's weird I
think it does happen to a lot of people
in different forms like yeah but if it's
like a pattern you should definitely
tell him I don't know what you can do to
make it better so he has to know like
there would be it's tough everywhere
right but maybe he's just like I don't
know if he's doing it to complete um
maybe he's just horned up like are you
guys like getting it on right so we're
bad okay so I thought that maybe it was
like only on nights when me men together
on before bed but it happens all the
time
it's not exclusive tonight's where
nothing happens got it that would really
bother me just like I hate being woken
Jackie it bothers me so much and it's
like something I just live with now for
years so for this girl it's like can he
do it without without you being woken up
you should definitely tell him it's an
interesting fact you should know it's
like if you were snoring I would want to
but you can't ignore it you can but like
but then you just like know something
about him I would want to know if I did
something like really maybe you should
tell him but like if he can't stop doing
it it's time doesn't bother you right go
to sleep god it's like I agree that was
a funny one and it's totally not a
deal-breaker I agree this is a very long
one and it's our last one because it's
very long WTF is going on in my office
basement I'm a lie I'm a lawyer I'm a
liar I'm a lawyer in a small firm we
have a creepy male partner who has had
very several sexual harassment claims
against him from former employees that
were settled out of court
we'll call him Bob there's something off
of that Bob that believes everyone just
believes is off it's hard to explain but
everyone agrees that he's like no
emotions he's weird rude unprofessional
inability to socialize and his creepy AF
he's also the boss's brother a few weeks
ago my paralegal star Bob loading eight
cases of water all different brands into
an office dolly it's important to note
that we have office managers who stock
our conference rooms with refrigerator
with refrigerated drinks so he certainly
wasn't doing that my paralegal and I
laughed about it and how odd Bob is and
we left it at that no big deal at this
point let me explain our building it has
five floors and a basement that is
unfinished the fourth and fifth floors
are a law firm the second and third
floors are an insurance company the main
floor adds a few restaurants on it the
basement is shared by
all the floors and is divided into
storage rooms our firm has its own
storage down there and it's locked 24/7
there are a few keys at the receptionist
desk that anyone can grab no one goes
down there very often
it's huge contains old boxes and
furniture with paper files on them a
week after my paralegals saw Bob
carrying this water I sent her to the
basement to retrieve an old file that I
needed to work on presumably the
McKenzie file she came back with it and
looked concerned she said tucked away
behind a bunch of boxes where all the
cases of water that Bob brought in she
said it was clearly placed in that spot
in an attempt to hide it so again we
were thinking what a [ __ ] weirdo bob
is I mean is he just thirsty why is he
hiding water is he making a zombie
apocolypse shelter why is he hiding
water as if like it's an emergency
situation we thought it was odd but
again not a huge deal I made a mental
note of it and I confided in another
lawyer at the firm we decided to keep
checking on the basement every few days
to see if anything else is odd we
checked a few days later we searched for
10 minutes before we found his stash he
was tucked away behind a stack of boxes
and this time it was covered up with a
blanket water stash yeah okay we pulled
we pulled the blanket off to take a look
this time the cases of water had doubled
there were 16 cases stacked in two
columns on top of the water bottles was
a coloman air mattress deflated inside a
carrying bag on top of that was a
cardboard box inside the box were two
new gallon of five buckets of 5-gallon
buckets instead nested in each other
with lids and also two tubes of sealant
what is that si se al ante salient wait
hold on let me google it se what did you
say se Ala NT sealant
hmm coding it's like something for the
home like you coat you get it like in
between your tiles yeah oh it's like a
glass protective enamel okay what I
think that's pretty
what the [ __ ] is he doing he's searched
the entire search the entire area
looking for canned goods non-perishable
food but we found nothing we are very
concerned but can't figure out what he's
planning here am i and my co-workers for
thoughts the bucket started pooping the
other one is to begin the sealant is to
seal the lid and really stop it from
smelling
of the bucket we have no idea really or
these options have also crossed our mind
he's housing mewling sex trafficking
victims down there temporarily from like
midnight to 5:00 a.m. until they are
picked up by the next the next morning
by transporter he's number two he's
getting ready to do something bad and
then flee go off the grid and he wants
to keep his stash ready to go but then
again I don't think that's much watery
that's much water that could fit in this
car like right and also just water like
wirings talking to me and that's what
they were looking for three he's going
to take all of us employees hostage down
there for it's a bunker for all things
apocalyptical yet there's no food
flashlights batteries etc we just don't
know here are things if I'm if for sure
is not he has money so it's not a place
to go when he's taking his mistresses
they could go to hotel room or something
else that actually is furniture good to
know he's not staying down there if his
wife ever kicked him out of the house
for any reason he'd stay in the
furnished office upstairs where there's
a TV couch and plumbing we were so
concerned that we had our police officer
friend secretly come take a look
he agreed it's very weird and said to
keep checking the basement once a week
and if additional items are added to let
him know so we are waiting
I need your opinions Claudia and Jackie
and all the toasters and maybe even the
TI a to give me a rational explanation
I'm a logical I'm logical normally but
this is Scott me stumped thank you thank
you is so weird that's hilarious first
of all second of what we were talking
about when we met diversifying our dear
toasters your office sounds so fun
you're here workers are like down there
in the basement with you and like do you
guys get any work done right like aren't
you like paid by the hour like bill by
the how are you what do you where do you
guys say you are during this time no
it's definitely odd and like I know what
you mean when like honestly when you
have like a gut reaction to something
and then you like brush it off like
you're always right and like if this guy
Bob wasn't creepy to begin with then
this story wouldn't be where you never
know like also I used to work in a
corporate office and yes there are like
snacks and drinks and food but like some
people would squirrel them away shelves
for me sometimes it runs out and like
you don't want to not have a water
bottle and there's no more water but
like but he has money no no but it's not
it's the convenience it's like people
would just like grab a pen hummuses from
the kitchen but like six cases of water
right no it's it's like 200 bottles it's
weird and buckets it's weird like what
if you guys moved all of it like moved
it away and like see what he did but
then she's getting herself involved in
making herself a target right now she's
like just a target for what there's
nothing criminal he's crazy you know but
like - but he'll never
see if you guys are spending so much
time down there everybody just like move
[ __ ] around and like see what happens
but they maybe he'll get spooked and
move it to like another location whereas
if he's doing something bad they know
about it and like they could help maybe
I can't this is like a dangerous dad
you're just like on a reared thing I
don't think it's a dangerous water is
like survival so it's like what are
gonna be down there for that you need so
much water to survive I mean maybe he's
like a conspiracy theorist right
apocalyptic the world is ending but like
why don't you bring food right maybe he
didn't think that far maybe it's still
getting his supplies together I don't
know I would like updates on this if you
I'm not gonna say your name but like if
you're watching which hopefully you are
um please keep us updated I mean why did
your police friends say he said that
it's definitely odd nothing illegal like
you could do about it but just to keep
an eye on that keep checking every week
but honestly the baby works so fun also
like you should someone should leave a
note for the brother the brother sounds
like he's the one in charge and like he
should know maybe he's like a scavenger
hunt you know what this is a case for
the TA the Special Victims Unit
these are their stories who do you think
is more dangerous not dangerous sleuthy
effective effective the SVU or the TI a
honestly the TI is like really pretty
[ __ ] effective and the SVU it's like
every episode it's like there's an
there's a thread left behind that that
makes sense at like I can watch the
episode and tell you exactly who the
person the killer is and with SVU it's
like DC's like in actual SVU and like
police cases like they so many times go
unsolved yeah and never in SVU at the
show right also something that SVU
doesn't do a good job on it's like being
in tune with what's necessary like the
TI Aikens all things in 10 to 5 5 to 10
seconds because of like digital and like
they know about all these apps and these
web safety news programs like SP is
still working off paper files you know
right they haven't gone digital yeah I
haven't watch se you know really long
time I guess ever since I stopped living
with my sisters it's it's still an
amazing show but like Mariska Hargitay
being the only oh gee I'm a squad see
you see she's leaving no she's leaving
no she's not she as I saw it on honey
news yeah it was a misleading caption
they said when she leaves she's gonna do
it in this way what's away I didn't read
it I'm gonna be
they're [ __ ] so misleading thank you
I can't believe I fell for it I'm
usually pretty good about that stuff I
think I mean I wouldn't know it would
have I would have gotten a People
magazine breaking news alert on my phone
I think you would have cuz you should
have all this look let me read it to you
tell me what you think it was extremely
misleading no I know I fell for it yeah
but like did you read the caption yes
okay II online so they put up a picture
of what's here in scrummy news they
always change everything online I see on
anymore um I do you watch any episodes
or just for you guys i watch reruns and
then on Netflix I'll like you know I'll
catch up on some of the new ones wait
where they post so many times a day oh
my god
where is Mushka also they should put a
Theo cam in there by the way put up the
Oh cam in the basement here all right
put it Theo cam in the basement oh my
god yes I'm what am i Daniel suggested
put a camera there yeah
use my camera is $30 ye home why I okay
this is what enews play put a picture of
merch congregate a in her in character
in one order SVU dedicated detective
Olivia Benson has to leave eventually
and we're should Margot Hargitay knows
exactly how she wants it to happen
that's not saying that it's happening
now is it technically no but I would if
the comments are calling them out for
being click baited no no don't leave
why did you have to leave is she leaving
now now people think that she's leaving
let me check Google just like Marsh
Quahog Rajesh easily know that no
rereading the caption she's not leaving
they want you to think she's leaving so
you'll click on their story I hate that
but I guess like also how does she want
to leave I didn't read it I want to know
death no she has it all or leave very
poorly how so his character um had went
through some some things and he it was
too much
yeah but I think that's actually
realistic that guess for sure but like
for TV like I needed more and we never
got a lot of answers because I think in
real life he left the show kind of
suddenly and and then in the next season
it like left Olivia Benson like broken
like it was so sad there's so much she's
in the show she's there's so much if
she's been kidnapped so many times and
that guy who played
pornstache in the first season ever
aren't as a new black well he kidnapped
turn like one on a bender of forcing her
to drink vodka oh my god that mean
like die I'm glad I missed Susan and
then she had to do the trial with it's
like I missed the simpler times when
it's just episode per episode like each
so right now it's like it's like they go
into each you know what I mean ya know
it used to be that you could watch an a
random episode of SVU and not have seen
the one before or Victor and you're fine
now there's much more of like a personal
story line so you really do need to
watch like Blue Bloods Blue Bloods is
got days it Monday
what's blue bloods on last night no I
don't know what network is it on CBS
says I think 28 is that a Sunday no
that's next week
I don't know where what's today I got a
PR package from blue buds I saw I guess
I heard my cries you left at my
apartment did you bring it back I
brought it here you were gonna wear it
on the show on Friday I probably bought
it back to my house yeah yeah I got a
teddy bear a mug thermos a script a real
script from last season and I'm working
on getting myself to set you have to get
a small role well that's a big picture a
small picture is that Johnny Wahlberg
falls me on Instagram as does Vanessa
who plays Jenko I should be I should be
right in for sure just to walk down the
street to get if I'm in New York they do
which is just so great because like
nobody films in New York anymore cuz
it's expensive but CBS can afford it
right also younger films in New York and
billions which I just finally finished
catching up on it's so good and I really
enjoy it and it's so smart and now like
all this business news that we're doing
like a really like I look at it from a
financial perspective and like we
reported some news on Friday and it's
like wow I should really short this
stock like think crazy things are
happening um and I just like really like
billions
it's weird I usually when I'm watching a
show I talk about a might and see I'm a
lot like my visceral reactions and I
[ __ ] hate Chuck Rhodes so I'm
surprised I didn't like really bring it
up but now that I'm done with the third
season I feel a little differently about
everyone and drama forward to season for
Johnny film in New York too and it's
very like New York like they went to
Saul Bass restaurant
Oh lend me and TPG went there it was
amazing it's so expensive really odd you
mean I had salmon he had steak I mean so
many cocktails yeah and we sat at the
bar I've been like lucky sitting at the
bar really only they have comfortable
chairs you know yeah only they have
chairs a back so they did it at a I'm
certain
so reminder that our trust movie of the
week is room it I don't know where it is
but you'll be able to find it cuz brie
Larson is everywhere
also I'm gone tomorrow but we're doing a
podcast episode tonight so you'll have
fresh content for the morning don't you
worry Wednesday and Thursday will be
covered with a co-host Ben will be blind
and then if you have suggestions
Jacky's what do you see people are in
New York that's the only way this works
you guys they have to be in New York and
you have to see that they're there now
and then just let me know
Jackie is working on Heather McMahon
yeah but that would be ideal
I don't know if she's in New York I mean
you know so I'm gonna be in DC I'm doing
a couple shows that are sold out so if
you've ever gotten a ticket I'm really
sorry then next week so much I have to
treacherous weeks ahead of me not this
week this week is good next two weeks oh
my god I got Albany and Buffalo cement
and you know what do they call that
upstate New York yeah yeah that's it my
digs there's nothing there's not a
better name um Albany is the state's
capital yeah very prestigious um Buffalo
is the bills right so if you want to
come see those scroll with no job comp
tickets and then I'm going to Atlanta
Atlanta is almost sold out and people
are yelling me because VIP sold out but
I'm sorry ladies there's something I
could do um I think your fault no
totally not yet like I just mean like
release more of you I pee tickets I'm
like I don't work at the venue and like
they don't listen to me alright if I ask
for something so can you imagine like
Amy Schumer is concert sold out and you
were messaging her directly right no but
it's like I like that I feel like people
like then it's cool yeah it's fun so
Buffalo Albany Atlantis almost sold out
Buffalo's almost sold out huntsville
alabama is sold out I think I'm so
excited Cleveland Cleveland also next
week on one of the days that you're here
Astrid and Kevin are joining us and I'm
so [ __ ] excited except I got called
for jury duty for the day there was so
much drama with this they're literally
just one morning Astrid and Kevin could
be here and I was on my way to Buffalo
so I moved my flight I made $200 to
[ __ ] Delta they're worth it move my
flight chew out like to the two o'clock
just to make it to Buffalo in time for
my show and did you have an Astrid
then literally last week Jackie gets
summoned for jury duty on the day that I
just put you on $2 remove my flight
right so I emailed jurors comm asking if
I could postpone it and they haven't
gotten back to me yet
and what do I do if they don't get back
to me I guess I could just miss it and
then say I emailed you guys I gave you
the date I was gonna postpone
they wouldn't let me do it on the
computer I tried everything look through
my files jury I'm actually ready to
serve on the jury like not a real case
but I'm ready to go to jury duty
like I realized the importance of it
ever since watching billions and you
know
the OJ Simpson trial and I think I could
be a pretty good juror except I have a
really busy schedule you ever see that
sort of curb where Larry gets out of
jury duty no oh my god it was like so
[ __ ] up I sometimes like it's funny
but like I never leave one no no I can't
believe what I'm watching yeah like he's
very into like stereotypes and like
making fun of like people's like gender
race religion and so he was he was on
trial for jury duty and the person who
was being accused of something was black
and he was like I don't think I could be
a fair and down sure because you know
he's black and he got off obviously cuz
they're not gonna let someone be on the
jury and it's like funny but like
sometimes he like takes it so far and
I'm like that show could never exist
today well it came back today oh that's
true but no sometimes to like go to such
extremes just to not do something and
it's like annoying it's like okay just
to just picked up flowers and drop them
at the funeral instead of stealing
flowers from the website and bringing
them to someone else and then getting
caught I feel like though back to the
point about like the like stereotype
type jokes it's like it's almost an even
playing field because he makes just as
much fun of like Asian people as he does
Jewish people like right he's eating the
most of Jewish people yeah so it's like
I guess it it evens out I don't know I
don't know why that show it's like
acceptable and like so many other things
aren't you know what I mean mm-hmm
I mean but is it because he makes fun
like no one is left and like no one no
one gets away like wherever you are I
don't know I just think it's I think
it's just because it's him and people
just have sex my friends yeah okay it's
funny but like sometimes I'm like
shocking yeah
it's truly shocking well an hour and 20
minutes later we are so glad to have
served you so if you want to come to any
of those shows head to girl with no job
com tickets are almost sold out and
everyone waits till last minute to buy
tickets and then when I come in it sold
out they're like why didn't you tell I
mean I did a hundred times up out here
on the streets like saluting for sure
it's it's true and it's like I know the
Atlanta one's gonna sell out and cuz
it's like already it's the big that's
one of my biggest venues and it's over
halfway sold and like it's still like a
couple weeks out you're gonna send a
personalized invitation to Brielle you
really should like something that'll
catch her eye like a forever like from
Venus of floor yes and then like with a
note so I know when I get there and I'm
gonna be Jewish okay no I say you were
doing a show I really put it my concern
of story once literally when today and I
chocolate on the show us all the time
Jerry O'Connell was out here promoting
shows for me
love him like I saw I stop at nothing to
promote my show we haven't even recap
Theriot calm he was great
today he showed premieres today I play
Tempe on my brother I'm gonna watch up
yeah me too and I'm gonna watch OC I'm
caught up it's like you guys they're
really struggling Geena announced her
divorce checking maybe we should record
the podcast episode after we watch
play-by-play okay do you want them so
slowly I know but like and I don't
really show tomorrow oh but you have to
wake up okay so I'll see if I can get a
screener okay can you probably can yeah
yeah we have we have that okay so thanks
guys for watching the morning toast
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
live Eastern Time we go live on YouTube
and Facebook soon we're just gonna do
YouTube cuz it Facebook is so shitty but
we'll give you time to migrate make a
youtube account so if you want to watch
live you should like us on Facebook you
should follow us on YouTube subscribe
give this video a thumbs up if you're
feeling you know frisky follow us on
Instagram for premium content always out
of the morning to our social accounts
where my personally has been extra
premium attracted by those also we're on
Twitter the morning shows and now the
podcast is available truly everywhere so
you have no excuse we got SoundCloud
where we've always been in iTunes where
we've always been it but now we're also
on Spotify which has really changed the
game for so many people
we're Alexa Alexa Alexa play the morning
toast podcast wait can you play a
podcast on iTunes from Alexa no because
Alexis Amazon and iTunes Apple music
isn't on Amazon it's about a fact isn't
on Alexa but Spotify is you probably
can't stay - Alexa you probably ought to
put it on your phone blue - then just
click it stitcher cast Vox public radio
where everywhere so just like no excuse
not to be a toaster and taste truster of
the movie was toaster movie of the week
was assigned it is ruining room and I
can't speak anymore so I don't need
Jacob Tremblay I love you Jacob bye
Jason thanks for making great merch
you